at this altitude I can my hands this
episode is brought to you by zip
recruiter you may have heard them
everywhere they're growing like crazy
they're an innovative platform for doing
several things but especially improving
the hiring process making it slick and
elegant and easy one of the hardest
parts of running any business growing
any business is finding and hiring the
right team I've seen this firsthand in
close to a hundred startups now god I'm
getting old from all over the world at
different stages of growth and nothing
can quite drain your resources and cost
you time and money
like making mistakes in hiring Zipp
recruiter developed their own system and
their own platform for helping you to
solve two of the biggest problems and
bottlenecks for employers posting jobs
easily and then making it even easier to
find the best candidates unlike other
job sites zip recruiter does in effect
the opposite of what you'd expect so
they do not depend on candidates finding
you their technology finds the right
candidate for you and in fact more than
80% of the jobs posted on zip recruit or
return a qualified candidate based on
your criteria that you select in just 24
hours
so no more juggling email reviewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates I've
been there done that don't recommend it
we're dealing with calls to the office
etc none of that simply screen rate and
manage your candidates all in one place
unzip recruiters dashboard and is a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show thanks
for that zip recruiter wants to allow
you to start posting jobs and trying
their services for free so if you're
thinking of hiring somebody you need to
find an executive assistant you need to
find a developer whatever it might be
try it out just visit zip recruiter com
forward slash Tim
and you can experience just how zip
recruiter has been used by businesses of
all different sizes to find the most
qualified job candidates again that's
zip recruiter dot-com a forward slash
Tim check it out give it a spin this
episode is brought to you by audible
which I've used for many many years
it comes with me everywhere on my
telephone in my pocket
I love audiobooks and they are one of my
favorite ways to pass the time more than
that to indulge myself to educate myself
with time that would otherwise go to
waste in some respects when I'm taking
walks when I'm cooking cleaning up the
house on the road for travel whatever in
those in-between spaces or as a
secondary activity I love using audible
to help me transform my downtime in a
way and it's allowed me to consume more
books many more books than I would
otherwise you can access an unbeatable
selection of bestsellers mysteries
thrillers and anything you could
possibly imagine really I have to to
recommend right off the bat one and I
recommend this even for nonfiction
purists this is a fiction book ready
player one by Ernest Cline
alright that's read by Wil Wheaton ready
player one by Ernest Cline check it out
the reviews are bonkers and this has a
cult following check it out and then
very selfishly I'll mention one that I
put together with one of you guys with
actually a listener of the podcast who
is also a huge fan of Seneca so the book
is Tao of Seneca ta o Tao of Seneca Sen
ECA subtitle practical letters from a
stoic master and this is effectively an
introduction to what I view is the
ultimate operating system for thriving
in high stress environments that is
stoicism it's become very popular among
top athletic Coaches CEO as a
fast-growing companies so check it out
that is for nonfiction folks who must
read or listen to nonfiction now of
Seneca practical letters from a stoic
master and as a listener of the Tim fair
show you have access to a 30-day trial
and your first audiobook is free so why
not go grab one of those ready player
one or Tao Seneca go to audible.com
forward slash Tim to start downloading
now membership includes one free
audiobook every month exclusive sales
such as 30% off all regularly priced
audiobooks and unlike streaming you own
your books once they have been
downloaded and I like to listen
oftentimes when I'm offline so you have
that benefit as well you can't make more
time folks just not manufacturing it
anymore and it's out of print you can't
make more time but you can make the most
of it
so turn your travel commute dog walk
whatever into something more with a free
trial at audible.com forward slash Tim
to learn more and start down
hello boys and girls sasquatches and
squirrels if that's a thing this is Tim
Ferriss welcome to another episode of
the Tim Ferriss show and I am sitting
listening to people whack mitts and
banana bags I'm imagining doing muy Thai
while I have positioned myself in what's
known as the cat room meow with red
padding over all the walls at on its
headquarters here in Austin Texas check
out on it
oh and then I t-dot-com not a paid
mention just a thank you and hat tip to
mr. Aubrey thank you sir
for lending me your space for recording
this episode is a much requested follow
up with Esther Perel at Esther Perel es
th ER p ER e l on twitter who has been
called the most important game-changer
in sexuality and relational health since
dr. Ruth and since I first met Esther
I've spent more and more time with her
and the more time I spend with her the
more impressed I am she is the real deal
and very very insightful her TED talks
on maintaining desire and rethinking
infidelity have at this point probably
more than 20 million views and she's
both seen and tested everything
imaginable firsthand with couples in 34
years of running her private therapy
practice in New York City Esther is the
author of the international bestseller
mating in captivity you've probably
heard of it which has been translated
into 26 languages she is fluent in nine
of those languages I've heard her in
person used them and his Belgian native
she now brings her multicultural pulse
to a new book which I highly recommend
checking out the state of affairs
subtitle rethinking infidelity her
creative energy is currently also
focused on the creation and hosting of
an audible original audio series where
should we begin but the state of affairs
is worth checking out in this episode
Esther answers your most uploaded
questions including how to foster
relationship or marriage longevity the
most effective ways to improve
communication and in relationships how
to deal with criticize
letting go of emotional baggage from
past relationships how to know when to
move on from a relationship that just
doesn't seem to be working and much much
more
yeah if you like Esther you're gonna
love this and her episode is one of the
most downloaded of all time previously
so here is more of the good stuff please
enjoy this wildly interesting in my
opinion QA from your questions with
Esther Perel
hi I'm Esther Perel thanks for sending
in your thoughtful questions and let's
dive in so this is a question from
Gregoire fee-free via Facebook we'd love
to ask her how to foster marriage
longevity and he exercises routines or
habit would be great especially around
fostering deeper emotional relationships
there is the first basics appreciation
just simply saying a lot of nice things
not taking things for granted not
forgetting to say thank you and please
just because it's the person that you
live with making compliments holding
hands kissing stroking sending sweet
notes buying flowers preparing breakfast
bringing the coffee to bed all those
sweet things that people do that
basically let you know that you're that
they live inside of you that you're
thinking of them even when they're not
there these daily appreciations they
they go a long way and it sometimes is a
real diligent effort to keep doing them
and then I am a strong fan of letter
writing I think that when you fly away
when you're away when you're sitting in
a cafe when you just have a moment to
drop a note that is not just on the
birthdays and on the anniversaries just
kind of hear your own musings about do
about you your life's together your
dreams where you're going how you met
what you remember what you fancy that is
actually very much the kind of the
telling of the story you know the story
of the couple there's a lot of intimacy
in there touch is a major experience of
intimacy I think when you do that humor
and things that kind of really encourage
the other person
which you recognize the matter and there
was at the most authentic could do this
thing this is some read is something you
really like take a few more days you
know you wanted to always take this
class go take discuss kind of ways in
which you encourage the other person to
to be the best version of themselves and
vice versa
be the best version of yourself with
them it's really basic what makes a
relationship sustain itself and be
before nurturing next Alicia Tenaya
Eichelberger via Facebook asks how to
lessen arguments in your marriage look I
think it's all about the art of speaking
and listening know there was a sculpture
a few years back by Bruce Newman and it
was a world peace project and he had 23
inch monitors with faces of the most
diverse group of people diverse races
ethnicities gender ages all of it and
every single person every face was
saying I'll talk and you listen you talk
and I'll listen they'll talk and we
listen you talk and we listen and it
just showed you this the the robustness
of this most difficult art which often I
would say listening is harder than
speaking but then for some people maybe
speaking actually becomes the hardest
thing in a relationship you can often
get the daily hassles in which you are
grinding at each other and in which
there's a friction going on don't sweat
the small things it's probably really
important in terms of how people deal
with with arguments in a relationship I
would say don't complain ask behind
every criticism there's often a wish and
if because if you believe that your
partner has to hum them done something
wrong that they didn't pay a long time
or anything and you wish that they had
done it right but instead of asking them
to correct it you basically tell them
that he can never do it well that you're
doing this on purpose that you know just
ask them to do it better next time you
know rather than would it kill you you
know
something simply do you think that next
time
you know you could set a monthly alert
so that you don't forget it's a very
different tone it's a very different way
of relating to the person there's no
contempt in that one which we know from
the research of John Gottman is one of
the four horses of Apokolips actually
I'm gonna give you the four horses get
it really important when is criticism
contempt stonewalling and defensiveness
those four are pretty much the the
killers in the in the land of arguments
and relationship decline you know try
not to talk with categoricals of all
always and never all or nothing
that probably is one of the most
important changes in vocabulary banish
them you know I always have to ask you
you'd never do this
no but the moment you say you never do
the person is gonna come up with the one
time that they know and that they've
done it so that they can defeat your
argument rather than really understand
that you're asking them to do it more
often which is exactly why I say ask
don't complain add some humor add some
humor is nothing that's gonna defuse
your arguments more than just putting
some perspective into it and not take
yourself so seriously show empathy at
the end of the day you know assume that
your partner has the same interest as
you to solve the stresses in your
relationship and for that to happen it's
a born that both of you understand and
appreciate the other person's point of
view do you really think that the other
person wants you to purposefully be
annoyed or hurt you or let you down
probably not it's all of that shift that
takes you out of relationships that are
mired in bickering chronic low intensity
warfare or high conflict because there's
a range there okay imagine I ask you as
you arguing turns toxic as industry
partner keep telling you that you can
never do it right or that they can never
do it right by you that every little
convo about who should set the table
will end up in a blowout about how this
function on your relationship is or that
two minutes into a fight one of you is
saying we should get a divorce or we
should break up that's what I'm calling
a high conflict couple
the opposite of the arguments is you
come in and you say I want to listen to
what you have to say I want to apologize
what can I do to make this better and
not what can you do to make this better
shift it around and you'll have magic
happening okay next question from Ben
Altman about jealousy how the majority
of non-exclusive relationships I've seen
seem to get done in by one of two
parties feeling possessive how do we rid
ourselves from these negative emotions
when I think that jealousy is intrinsic
to love I don't think of it as a
negative emotion it is part and parcel
of the experience I think that sometimes
it's an interesting experience in this
particularly in the u.s. where people
often will say I'm not jealous because
I'm angry as if jealousy is is a feeling
that is politically incorrect it doesn't
have much popularity these days jealousy
is an erotic rage jealousy is the
feeling you have when your partner takes
they love their desire their excitement
to someone else and you want it more
directed toward you it is thwarted away
from you so I don't suggest that you rid
yourself from that emotion I suggest
that you integrate the emotion it tells
you something it generates action it
generates conversations and it is not
the same as possessiveness they're
related but they're not the same on the
other end here is a simple formula for
possessiveness if you love someone set
them free if they love you they'll come
back Joseph DiBernardo posted this
question on Twitter yesterday what is
the best way to move on after divorce
and deal with post marriage depression
sadness especially for men who find it
difficult to speak about their inner
pain of the divorce in the lack of
connection Joseph I'm gonna tell you
something men have a much harder time
post-divorce emotionally and physically
than women maybe not financially but in
every other respect they do
they suffer much more they're more at
risk for accidents for drinking they
take a hit because they need women even
though they want to pretend that they
don't it goes against the cultural
narrative I think that what you have in
this moment is two things one you
absolutely want to reach out and I think
if you have friends that you can talk to
that would be great male or female
friends if you want to go to a men's
retreat to a men's group there is
nothing comparable to it at this point
then groups where guys come together to
talk about their inner life what's going
on with them it's empowering it builds
solidarity it takes you out of the
loneliness out of the shame out of the
isolation out of the feeling of failure
all of it all of it there's nothing more
powerful than a group of people that
come together and hold one person while
that person can't hold themselves it's a
spiritual challenge it's not just a
relationship challenge so you need to go
get energy you deplete it and one of the
ways that you get energy is by going to
do something for others go help others
the research is very clear the most
powerful antidepressant is doing for
other people it puts things in
perspective it makes you feel like you
have something to offer it makes you
feel appreciated by the people of whom
you're helping it changes the entire
equation of what's going on inside of
you right
I think journaling is an important part
of mourning on occasion if it works out
it may be a good thing to have a
triangle conversation with your ex a bit
of time later where you kind of clear
things and you try to have a different
conversation than the ones that you had
when things really tanked I think that
it's also useful on occasion to go to
your family and to ask a little bit
about what has been the history of
relationships in the family so that you
get to get to learn a little bit as well
what are some of the unknown legacies
that you carry inside of you the main
thing is don't isolate yourself that's
that's it and you will see that when you
start to talk
generally appreciated they don't know to
do it themselves but they like it when
they feel that they have something to
offer when they made to feel significant
because someone else opens up to them
it's the opposite sometimes of what we
anticipate okay
good luck to you the real Josh Hill asks
on Twitter I'd love to hear her talk
about letting go moving past the anger
from being cheated on the anger towards
the partner that cheated the friends
that seemingly abandoned the one that
was cheated on and the anger towards the
self were not seeing the relationship
falling apart sooner and trying to fix
it a lot of self blame here right a lot
of self blame and a lot of anger at the
other people for not being there for you
you know often when people are cheated
on if the first thing is to say what's
whether my my what's wrong with me what
am I missing
why am I not enough or why didn't I see
it but sometimes there is a reason that
people engage in trauma denial that
people don't want to see because when we
don't see it protects us it preserves a
certain coherence to our life it's not
just because we are fools and idiots and
easily duped so be careful about not
pouring all kinds of self-loathing unto
you what kind of an idiot are you how
could you not know it what kind of a guy
lets himself be walked on like this we
just should have known you should have
seen you should have done more ask
yourself questions but from a place of
responsibility not from a place of
beating yourself down and blaming
yourself because then you can't think if
you put yourself that much down and you
feel so terrible about yourself you
cannot really think all you can do is
just protect yourself from getting the
blows now there are phases in the
recovery as well the first thing is just
simply you know the hurt the anger the
confusion the disbelief the
disorientation the the loss of the
predictable future the idea that
whatever you thought your life was going
to be it isn't going to happen all of
that and you need to really respect that
all these feelings are going to hit you
all at once
and it's gonna be an avinash of all this
maelstrom and that's normal it's in the
nature of the beast it's really really
normal and gradually at the occasion you
will mourn this and you will think you
know it wasn't good anyway and at other
times you will say I could have
continued this way how could she destroy
all of that and then you can ask your
friends talk to them did you see things
did you try to warn me did I not listen
where you are equally as surprised as me
but you need to know that there are
phases of recovery I've written about it
extensively in my new book you go from
the crisis and you go and you move into
the insight phase where you start to
make sense of all of this why did this
happen what can I learn from this what
does it say about our relationship what
does it say about me what does it say
about her and then there is where does
this take me now what am i lessons where
am I going to go with that and and and
try not to have this just become a
script for anger and bitterness I think
that when you're very angry all the time
you basically also protect yourself from
not being too sad from not being hurt
from not feeling vulnerable it kind of
props you up to be angry and it gives
you a sense of righteousness but be
behind the anger is often a real sense
of collapse and let yourself go there
it's okay it really hurts to just be
angry isn't gonna make it for you and
how to allow yourself that by being with
people who you trust to with next to
whom you can fall apart who won't judge
you for it who understand heartbreak it
is a human emotion it's the one of the
oldest experiences we've had and it's
part of our humanity you won't avoid it
you won't avoid it let yourself feel the
pain and the hurt and the sadness and
cry and then you'll come through it you
know I'm thinking about a guy that I
wrote about in my book who whose was act
actually it was his brother who cheated
on him with with the girl that he used
to date and for years for years every
time a girl liked him he thought you
know who's who whose I else is hiding
here behind that I'm not seeing
he really carried it with him for a long
time it takes a while till you begin to
trust again till you begin to feel good
about yourself again till you feel that
you are able to be loved and lovable it
really goes very deep this experience it
taps into our sense of self-worth all of
that and I hope that the stories that I
wrote about in the book will help you
with that they were meant for that they
were meant to help you okay thank you
run Johnny 86 writes on Twitter is it
harder to find true love as you get
older and progressively more intelligent
do you have to be young and stupid to
find love the most people in search of a
partner settle at some point glad you
back but I'm gonna challenge the premise
of your question a little bit you know
what does it mean that you're going to
settle that you I think the main thing
is this when you are younger you allow
yourself the experience of meeting
someone seeing where it takes you and
folding with the story and an embracing
the surprise of where this thing is
going that you didn't expect but when
you're looking for a relationship as an
adult and you come with your
expectations
you often thwart the possibility for a
story to unfold and to surprise you
because you're sitting there with an
inventory and you're not really allowing
for the unknown to to open itself up to
you and to take you on a ride that you
didn't see coming I think most of the
dating that involves a checklist is
doomed
that's that's the best way I can say it
it's it's anti romance it's anti story
and stories are the way we live our
lives it's it's a list of items and
often you will find that people match
all the items on your list and the
feeling isn't there because the feeling
is something that emerges that develops
through interaction through shared
experience through the creation of a
shared story together and I don't
believe that that is any less possible
as an adult in fact when you are older
you are clearer about what you like what
you resonate with you know yourself
better and from
please you are more able to appreciate
the person that is in front of you but
it's not like you have to be young and
foolish to fall in love now absolutely
now there is no age for it people fall
in love at any age at this point people
have the opportunity for the first time
in history to actually start entire new
lives in their 50s 60s 70s love doesn't
have an age to it
we love differently because we are more
mature because we accept certain things
more and because we accept other things
less and we don't necessarily call that
settling settling means what I only
found six items on my list out of the
ten that's not the way we do it we make
a choice and a choice always involves a
loss and at some points we make certain
choices that I may be more rational or
more forward-looking we understand that
there are certain things we need in
order to live with someone and that
there are certain people with whom we
could have a fantastic love affair and a
fantastic adventure but maybe not
necessarily build a whole life together
and in that sense we become we are able
to hold more elements at the same time
and make a decision that embraces
ambivalence it's something that that I
call maturity not settling Davi Lena
asks through Twitter when do you know a
relationship is done that is such a
powerful question it's really but but
what do we mean by done that you don't
like who you have become that you don't
like what you're doing that you don't
like how you read how you're being
reflected back that the relationship has
lost itself of assets sense of aliveness
and vitality or that it has become toxic
when is dying on the vine what do we
call done yeah I think that the main
element that is really for me the kiss
of death the end of a relationship is
contempt because it's really involves a
profound sense of dehumanization when
that tone that just says look at you
come on what is this is that you you
call this a relationship that sense of
of this of self loathing and contempt
it's very hard to come back from that
you can fight you can be critical you
can
complain you can be volatile you can
have a lot of things in a relationship
because from there you can always come
back into sweet repairer tender
connecting etc and you just go to the
cycles of connection disconnection and
repair which is the triad of
relationships but contempt is a real
tough one
the belittling the infantilizing the
demeaning the degrading all these
categories of relationships which
basically amount to abusiveness to me
that is a moment where no relationship
really is done because what it means is
that one in order to protect oneself one
needs to leave unless you're the one
doing it and then in order to protect
yourself and the other you need to
change Thank You Kelsey Hyman asks on
Facebook how does she handle her critics
oh god that is a wonderful question does
she read and comment on the internet
trolls for her book reviews podcasts etc
how does she deal with the people who
think they know more about relationship
than her so I love this question because
it allows me to say something you know I
am often considered a thought leader or
an expert I actually see myself much
more as a student and as a person who is
avidly curious and continues to learn on
a daily basis rather than as someone and
positions herself as knowing I think
about these things a lot I often can
sound very confident but I'm sure of
nothing one thing I can say is that
nothing I say is made up but that
doesn't mean it's true I also don't
think there is one truth and I think
that I am a person who continuously
seeks to be challenged I go and then
check with other people am I missing
something is there something I didn't
think about is there validity in the
criticism I invite conversation dialogue
confrontation and disagreement where it
hurts where I find myself at a loss is
when people are taking one thing I say
completely distorting it Carrie Carrie -
Carrie featuring me or
what I say when I try so hard to embrace
complexity and nuance and kind of feel
completely flattened by a complete
misunderstanding of what I say often to
the extent where I wonder if the people
actually really read my work engaged
with me and I wish that the critics
actually came to me and asked me and
engaged with me and challenged me rather
than just you know trash me I generally
try not to read too much of it because
it hurts and because I don't feel that
there is an invitation for the dialogue
whoever comes to me directly
respectfully and says I disagree I think
you're wrong etc etc I will speak with
whoever is avoiding me and just going
behind my back and using the Internet to
anonymously or not anonymously trash I
think is participating in the same
culture and in the trashing culture of
the moment and with all the consequences
that we all know are involved in this so
that's my relationship to criticism I
welcome it when it's done you mainly
when it's done respectfully SAP Frank
one asks on Twitter
we often hear communication is key in a
relationship but as I believe she has
mentioned in her book too much can
hinder desire what then is the juice to
millou okay listen you make me think of
a song by Carly Simon no secrets in
which she has a line sometimes I wish I
didn't know those secrets of yours you
know I think that the free love of the
60s came with a view of honesty and
transparency and letting it all hang out
there and while it kind of came with the
rise of individualism as everything that
a person experiences is at the center it
matters it needs to be met I also think
that the other side of this kind of
wholesale sharing is an ethos of candor
like that is that there needs to be
consideration politeness and I find that
those two quality
are often in short supplies in
contemporary relationships there's this
notion that we expect the partner to
just hold on to all of our feelings and
make us feel better
rather than engage a little more in our
own self soothing and in our own
self-regulation and in going and venting
to others it actually is always been the
case that people vented to people
outside of the relationship in order to
be able to sustain what happened on the
inside but it's about kind of don't let
your emotional hemorrhoids bleed like
that inside your house all the time I
don't know that this is always the best
we of course want communication we want
exchange we want deepening and real
meeting with the other but I'm not sure
that the kind of all out there is the
only model and what you're gonna hear
from me always is that there isn't one
way only
there isn't one size fits all and so
while I answer you in one way I may
answer someone else differently and I
think it's that richness that I want us
all to hold here on occasion let it be
you don't have to react to everything
not everything is a ten certain things
are just a two they're not really that
important and that's another song but I
think we really need to be able to harm
on occasion and in terms of they're not
turning everything on the desire it's
really this the questions the interest
that you want to keep for your partner
or vice versa
are a way in which you remain curious
interested engage with the other person
as a person the way that we often are in
the beginning where we are just
interested in who is this person and
what happens over time is that people
often feel that they know their partner
as if they belong to them as if they're
just an extension of them and that's
naturally a contrived illusion of safety
it's not true in the face of the unknown
which exists right in our midst there is
that mystery of the other and the
mystery of the other is simply available
once you continue to be curious about
them rather than assume this kind of
familiarity that's what I'm trying to
say about the connection to desire
because if desire
exists in that space of exploration of
discovery of curiosity
once you remain curious to your partner
once you continue to think of them as a
person not just as your partner the
desire can continue to thrive as well
the next question you're asking is what
according to her observations and
experience are the essential blocks to
build a strong foundation between
partners and what is essential in a
relationship to maintaining longevity
there are many many pieces that I think
are part of driving relationships but
I'll give you a few just the ones that
come up now and then if we meet again
you'll ask me again and I'll give you a
few others yes I'll go on number one not
everything must be said I think that
that in light of the culture that we
live in today I will probably say not
everything must be said if we were
talking and meeting in other parts of
the world I would say the exact opposite
more things need to be spoken sometimes
okay just so you understand these things
these answers are always taking place in
a context and specifically in a cultural
context the second thing I think one of
the most important combinations in a
relationship is the combination between
empathy and responsibility it's your
ability to continue to see to your
partner and from their own point of view
is to enter the shoes of the other and
on the other side your ability to take
responsibility for that which is yours
your own contribution your mistakes your
flaws just I'm sorry I did this actually
next time I'll do differently I own it I
own it
the minute you can own something it
gives you freedom rather than thinking
that all problems and all changes
actually belong to the other person and
the next piece that is really essential
to the balance to live in a relationship
is the ability to navigate separateness
and togetherness you know to have space
to have individuality to have
self-expression to have your own friends
to have your own experiences that are
not all related to the couple and then
also to have very strong things that
belong to the couple but some couples
have a
the overlap of the concentric circles
and some couples have a complete overlap
so there's a range some people love to
just have a big big big togetherness and
a small separateness and others the
other way around but it is that
negotiation and it changes over life
it's not one and the same when you meet
and then fifteen years later the next
thing for a long relationship is
flexibility its adaptability it's your
ability to say you know we used to do it
like this this worked for ten years it
doesn't work anymore
change and that thinks that people are
much more able to do in their companies
and in their workplaces than they are
willing to do at home
this is often a real static attitude
towards the relationship we met a
certain way we set it up a certain way
my rule your world my responsibilities
your especially and it goes on like that
for 35 years you know and then we
collapse so the ability to just come
together and say I need something
different let's change this I love
couples who have an annual summit and
kind of review their relationship where
is it going how are we doing you know or
even monthly just because it shows
intentionality it shows attention it
shows care the same way that you water
your plants you know rather than a kind
of letting it go in this affair for a
long time on and that kind of diligence
makes a big difference and then the last
one I will say for longevity and for
driving relationships because so many of
you had the question about what makes a
relationship last is engaging with new
experiences not just comfortable and
pleasant experiences those those make
for a real familiarity and security and
stability in the couple but what really
makes it try what brings it alive ness
and vitality is the engagement with new
experiences outside of the comfort zone
because they breed new cells and all the
research is confirming that at this
point novelty breeds testosterone it's
and it's not never T of sex sex
positions it's really different ways of
being with oneself in the relationship
and with each other so all of that
combined you have a good chance to go
for quite a while Aleksander ds4 on
Twitter and Aspen Jen I'm will
Mulcahy on Facebook are asking how do
millennials bring back romance and
emotional intimacy what do you see are
the biggest flaws of young men in their
20s and how they communicate with women
what advice do you have for them I'm
gonna divide this into look there isn't
much romance when people make dates on
text all the time on occasion today
romance will be a phone call in the past
romance was a card it's like you know
who still gets picked up at the door who
still gets brought back at the door who
gets some of cold the next morning I
mean it's all these things that are
often seen as kind of passe and an old
century but in fact I don't think the
repertoire is particularly changed what
the text doesn't go very far in terms of
flattery does it anything that goes
beyond the bare minimum his romance
because romance is pining romance is
seduction romance is flirtation and that
is a cultivated art by which you are
gradually making the other person melt
in your arms but for that you have to be
able to say I want you and that means
you have to experience the vulnerability
of putting yourself out there and it
seems that these days too many young
people are quite reluctant to experience
the vulnerability and the uncertainty of
not knowing of making that phone call
and hoping that somebody's gonna answer
and it won't be her dad you know that
used to be and and that butterfly thing
has kind of been done away with
the stuff is way too much immediate
gratification so there is no space in
between
- silly experience the excitement and
the anticipation and the uncertainty but
all of that was part of romance that was
the romantic blood the romantic plot it
plays itself out in the will it happen
won't it happen the pneuma is irrelevant
that's but you know a romance novel is
300 pages for the last piece and the
last pieces there is only one page it's
300 pages of will it or will it not and
that's romance now
in terms of the question of what to do
take the risks take the risks don't just
grow in a bar just it's not just a booty
call
you know put yourself out there and say
I want you and I'll take the time I
coach this guy recently and it was very
sweet you know woman basically calls it
off seven o'clock Friday night you know
not a very nice thing to do
she's busy she's a meeting whatever and
I mean it goes into a whole you know
shinai way does that mean she's not
interested she's interested I just said
look text her back and say I understand
makes it you know yeah but twice as much
time for tomorrow please come back with
something that is funny but that breeds
confidence and that is assertive and
that says I'm still very interested and
you owe me a double dose she liked it
she liked it now if she doesn't if she
has no interest in him then she will
tell him at that moment please don't
bother but if she has slight interest in
him he will gain a lot of points with
one of those things I've done more and
more you know coaching people lately
just looking at your tinder feeds just
the kind of exchanges not only do they
like romance they like they like
anything that says to people you know
you're interesting to me and I would
like to meet you just it's really thin
it's really thick so there is the issue
of romance but there is the broader
question simply of how do people these
days literally turn each other on with
their minds not just the other ways okay
men there's a beautiful book by Rob
Garfield called questioning the male
code which I recommend for many of you
but the mayor code often comes with a
fix-it attitude and fix it is I have an
answer I have a solution and it is part
of the making of masculinity competence
performance problem-solving so
unfortunately in the relationship with
women
fix-it doesn't often work because many
times she wants to only talk and she
wants to share the experience she
doesn't really want to be told what to
do she's quite competent she quite knows
what to do and if you give her
unsolicited advice she'll experience it
as patronizing so the flipside a fix-it
is empathy is two things tell me more
tell me more main said that's all you
need to do you don't have to solve it
you just have to ask her if she wants to
continue to talk about it and you want
to engage in empathic murmurings oh
really oh that's tough oh wow you know
that kind that says I'm listening it is
most of the time what she needs if you
want to give advice ask her if she wants
to hear it and otherwise which is she
asks for it the fear that people have
sometimes that guys have when they say
tell me more is that she's gonna
studying it we'll never stop saying if
she says we have to talk he says how
long and in fact when you say tell me
more the answer will be much shorter
than if you don't
and she still isn't sure that you really
get it so that's really the main the
main piece in terms of men in
communication and I'm not so sure that
it is different for young guys or for me
even men my generation boomers it's
really you don't have to have an answer
and you don't have to feel like you
making it to solve the problem or make
the feelings go away you actually need
to do less and your challenge is to
still feel competent even if you do less
but you will be much more appreciate
actually I had one of the little
thoughts that when we talked about that
the things for longevity and the things
for for deepening the intimacy and all
of these things which I didn't talk
about which is people sitting in the
morning and having breakfast watching
outside the window listening to music
together dancing together for a moment
you know the average pop song is 2.3
minutes if you just do that it doesn't
take a long time people sometimes think
it's so much work to maintain this
intimacy it actually is not
it's 2.3 minutes
to listen to some of the most beautiful
love songs ever written and reconnect
with that feeling between the two of you
okay so I hope that I've given you some
ideas inspirations food-for-thought in
the pursuit of your own loving and
driving relationships I want to add a
piece to Gavin Lina's question when do
you know that a relationship is done
David and I was talking about the Four
Horsemen of Apocalypse that a famous
researcher on the relationships John
Gottman talks about and I wanted to
expand a little bit on that you know one
is criticism and okay it's quite easy
right it's complaining it's picking at
the other person it's seeing what you do
as circumstantial and seeing the other
person as characterological right if if
you're in a bad mood it's because you
had a tough day but if the other person
doesn't act very nice least because
they're actually generally a mean person
you know or a bad-tempered person rather
than they too may have had a bad day
right so all the elements that have to
do with criticism the way that people
just know that the other person and just
grow and circle around the same
grievances over and over again that's
the piece that he's talking about
stonewalling is silent treatment it's
basically you know withdrawing removing
oneself and letting the other person
stand out there and talk to the walls
that's another major Horsemen of
Apocalypse defensiveness the fact that
you know you can't bring anything up
without the other person instantly
rejecting defensive going nature instead
of just saying yes thank you for telling
me let me think about this or simply I
that doesn't feel good but you know
probably I do yes I do do that you know
I don't mean to but I do or or or it's
an old bad habit of mine or something
that acknowledges that stands
accountable that does intensity yeah but
you you know and then says you did worse
and then starts to pile up you know and
everything you said the other person
counters right away with something worse
so that they never have to look at the
thing that you said you said yeah but
yesterday you all of that hate that
defensiveness it's it's very rich
defensiveness but it basically leaves
you without the feeling that you ever
can bring something up and that it will
be responded to for its own sake and
then contempt that's the one that I
think is the the final killer the for
for a relationship and that when I
already detailed for you I wanted you to
have a sense about this is for your
question actually about the relationship
being done but also the question that
was asked by Alicia asked about how to
lessen the arguments in your in your
relationship so the opposite of these
four killers of relationship have to do
with how the people stay connected in
the midst of disagreement I think the
most and this is something I wanted to
expand more for Alicia's question is
that we really need to know something
about arguing in a relationship it often
has very little to do with the content
of the argument itself when couples
enter into a vicious cycle and they are
reactive and they escalate and they
bicker and they fight it doesn't really
matter the subject any more at a certain
point if it's the kids or the car or the
money or what they were gonna do for
Christmas it all is gonna sound the same
and what you're gonna hear is that
people end up being in an interaction
where they don't feel acknowledged they
don't feel validated they feel dismissed
they feel that the other person competes
with them that they are outmaneuvered
and it doesn't matter what they talk
about
so the real truth about conflict in
relationships is that the form precedes
the content the way these arguments
unfold is one and the same if it is this
or if it is about Greenpeace in South
Korea it makes no difference it's no
longer about the issue itself and once
you know that then you have to go at the
forum and the
is what the people are doing to each
other while they say the things they say
and what they're doing is this long list
of just come true
the opposite of dismissing and
disqualifying and invalidating is
acknowledging and recognizing and
validating and empathizing and that
doesn't mean you don't agree so there's
a very very good method developed by
Mark Howard Markman sorry it's called
prep and it's a book fighting for your
marriage it's actually quite good and in
prep basically they tell you in negative
communication you pretty much have ten
seconds before you get ready for the
rebuttal that's about as much as you can
listen to something that your partner
says and that you disagree with in 10
seconds is three sentences so to where
you minimize the arguments is by
beginning to practice reflective
listening it's tedious it's annoying but
it's highly effective what I'm hearing
you say and you repeat is there more and
you repeat and vice versa and then when
you talk you do X Y Z statements when
you do X in situation Y I feel Z when
you don't even look up when I walk into
the house because you're busier to
computer the whole time and I am trying
to make connection with you I feel like
I don't matter and you don't love me
something like that that is very
different from you couldn't give a food
about me and any time I come home you on
purpose pretend like you didn't hear it
hey that's an attack from that attack
all you're gonna get is a defense and
the defense can be a counter-attack or
stonewalling or a defensive Ness or a
criticism or a contempt the here you
have your four horses the sentence is
broken down in such a way that if I have
an experience of what you do that is not
the same as my defining that this is
what you do it says that when you do
this I experience it in a certain way
and that's my feeling and you
can't argue with the other person's
feeling you can argue with another
person trying to define you and to
define you negatively that XYZ is
intensely transformative when people
really begin to practice it so that's
one way out of the little health of
chronic arguments okay let me there take
a few other questions that I haven't
that I haven't spoken about how can men
effectively handle their sex drive asks
the V Weinstock look I don't know
exactly what you mean by effectively
handle their sex drive if you're asking
you know what two men do when they are
horny and and and they want to have sex
but they don't have partners available
or they have a partner who steady
partner who is not there at that moment
or not interested I think one of the
things that I would say is this sex for
men is very much connected to what goes
on inside of them if they're angry if
they're happy if they're anxious if
they're depressed if they feel good
about themselves and if they don't some
men turn to sex to soothe themselves
when they're anxious
besides when they feel good that's a
given
some men experience sex as the one and
only language to which they can
experience emotional intimacy some men
experience sex as the only language to
whom to which they can feel tender the
soft connected it won't be the first
time that you will hear women describe
guys who open up who they feel are truly
there who are really intimate with them
only in sex because it is the sanctioned
language for guys to experience but
otherwise are often forbidden emotions
for men so that's for me when you asked
about effectively handling sex drives it
has to do with that it has to do with
being not just monolingual having many
languages available having many ways to
wake to take care of our needs of our
feelings and not just one that's the
effectiveness of sex is to not have it
be ex the only thing available for the
rest I'm not sure that there is a unique
way to effectively deal with drives
but one thing you need to know sex is
not a drive you don't die from not
having sex you die from not being
touched but you don't die from not
having sex it's a motivational system
it's not a drive that's not the same
eben is asking what are some of the
suggestions and resources that she has
for couples who want to explore having a
more monogamous relationship not Polly
but more flexible than traditional
monogamy especially when it comes to
navigating boundaries emotions and
sexual health
it's a beautiful question so first of
all there's the movie that comes out
right now that our hospital is movie
called monogamish it's premiering in New
York actually this week so that would be
it's a very nice movie to see together
because it really opens up the
conversation and for me the open
relationship is less about what people
actually do than the openness of the
conversation itself many people don't
nearly want to do as much as they want
to do that they could if they wanted
they don't want to feel that they live
with the restrictions of the boundaries
and then it's a conversation what is it
that you miss what is it that you feel
drawn to what would you like to
experience do you wanna experience it
alone you want to experience it together
do you want me to know about it is it a
turn-on for you if I tell you or do you
actually not want to know about it and
often you'll find you have one of each
in a couple is it do you wanna be is it
something that you want that is fleeting
that is just that if you meet someone
you want the possibility of letting
something unfold and see where it takes
you is it when you travel because you're
often away or is it that you have been
with me since you are 17 and you want to
know other partners because you've never
known others beside me it's this whole
conversation and not to take it
immediately as something is missing I
can't give you everything I should be
everything for you if you have any other
interests it must mean that I'm not
enough it's really that conversation and
what you will find is that the couples
for whom this is an adjoint interest the
conversation itself is often very
enlightening very vibrant and very very
intimate because the possibility
of talking to your partner about your
longings for that which takes place
outside and it to have it be recognized
and accepted is a deeply intimate
conversation the the recognition of your
freedom of your of your erotic freedom
on which you may not not act but that it
exists even in fantasy even in curiosity
in longing in interest is profoundly
intimate for couples and then you talk
about do we want to do I want to know
what do we tell each other do we notify
in advance do we tell after it has
happened what is it that you want to
know and understand that you don't have
a necessarily a symmetric need one of
you may want to know more one of you
doesn't one of you likes to share one of
you doesn't you don't have to be one in
the same and then you come back and you
and you examine it works for us it
doesn't work for us it makes brings us
closer it makes us too nervous it now in
the end it isn't it's not a good thing
for us or not right now because we have
young kids and we're not equal oh
because one of us is not working and
we're not equal or because one of us has
been sick and we're not you know by
definition they needs to be a certain
level of equality in the relationship
for the conversation to not be a power
maneuver both people need to have the
same possibilities they may not do it
want to act on them but they need to
both know that they could if they wanted
and if that's part of the agreement and
then you come back and you examine this
is this good for us this is work when I
say work meaning do we feel enriched by
it or do we feel like it's depleting us
that it's taking away from us that it
does limit me now we thought it would be
a good idea but it's not really or this
has actually opened up things between us
we've had a whole different level of
honesty between us a whole different
depth of communication that never
existed before we bring back different
parts of ourselves the reunions are
beautiful we make love before we go off
to meet someone else we only accept it
when one of us is travelling it's a very
rich conversation and it's often
many many conversations before anybody
even acted on any of this that's how
this process goes then you can read some
books in retail Minos book open you can
read six at dawn I mean that's the end
and you can talk to other people who
actually practice consensual
non-monogamy varieties thereof and how
it works for them you get ideas but
often people don't tell you that that's
what they do because it's so negatively
judged so it's not like you can go and
ask them how to do how do you raise your
children because I'm looking for some
ideas but you will find people who are
willing to talk and have experienced it
for years so they they practiced at it
that doesn't mean it's what works for
you but it inspires you it gives you
what you should be thinking about and
that's how I would start this thing the
last question I will do how do I help
people come to terms and come to accept
themselves you know for me
self-acceptance is really a process of
maturation it I don't expect people in
their 20s to easily accept themselves so
I I do put this on a spectrum of time
but I think the fundamental experience
of accepting yourself is that you accept
that you are flawed you accept the
things that are beautiful about you and
you begin to feel with I'm good enough I
mean that's the essence it's not I'm
perfect it's I'm good enough or I'm
flawed and I make mistakes but they
don't thank me I don't feel instantly
massively embarrassed and ashamed about
them I'm able to look at them and just
say okay I'll do better next time I'll
do it differently next time I learned
from this it's that process that is self
acceptance I mean I remember making
mistakes and they're not sleeping for
three weeks at a time you know and
churning and obsessing about it and
replaying it in my head today I do some
of these mistakes and I just think oh
okay I know that mistake and now I don't
like it it doesn't feel good but it
doesn't [ __ ] me anymore in the same
way I think that's the level of
self-acceptance ever simplest is also
knowing what you want and and feeling ok
about it's not not
like you have to continuously justify
explain apologize it's a it's what I
call the healthy sense of entitlement
not a grandiose sense of entitlement
self-acceptance is self-confidence
self-acceptance is also the ability to
live with your lack of confidence and
your insecurities and your uncertainties
and to say this is an area where I feel
deeply insecure and it's part of who I
am I have it all the time all of this is
self acceptance it's your ability to
live with your sense of ambivalence the
things about yourself that you like and
that you don't like the things that you
feel really good about and the things
that you are very troubled by the
ability to integrate those two that's
the ability to live with ambivalence
about oneself is an essential ingredient
of self-acceptance it's all of that and
for me it's a process of maturation over
life
this is not something new you just one
day have it grows on you
slowly physically emotionally in terms
of lifestyle you know what you like you
accept it you don't think that you don't
force yourself anymore to biess who
you're not you're okay in your skin I
often say you know if I had the
confidence of today with the looks of
them but when when I was young I didn't
have the confidence it's a it's an
interesting thing that has a lot more to
do with life experience than with any
actual trainings that you're gonna have
but uh that's my suggestions for
self-acceptance goodbye thank you very
much and I hope we talk again soon and I
hope that you can draw from some of
these answers and feed on them for a
while until until the next meal as we
say van Appetit right hey guys this is
Tim again just a few more things before
you take off number one this is five
bullet Friday do you want to get a short
email from me and would you enjoy
getting a short email for me every
Friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend and five bullet
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up in
the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend
so if you want to receive that check it
out just go to 4-hour workweek dot-com
that's four hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you will get the very next one and
if you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by audible
which I've used for many many years
it comes with me everywhere on my
telephone in my pocket I love audiobooks
and they are one of my favorite ways to
pass the time more than that to indulge
myself to educate myself with time that
would otherwise go to waste in some
respects when I'm taking walks when I'm
cooking cleaning up the house on the
road for travel whatever and those
in-between spaces or as a secondary
activity I love using audible to help me
transform my downtime in a way and it's
allowed me to consume more books many
more books than I would otherwise you
can access an unbeatable selection of
bestsellers mysteries thrillers and
anything you could possibly imagine
really I have to to recommend right off
the bat one and I recommend this even
for nonfiction purists this is a fiction
book ready player one by Ernest Cline
alright that's read by Wil Wheaton ready
player one by Ernest Cline check it out
the reviews are bonkers and this has a
cult following check it out and then
very selfishly I'll mention one that I
put together with one of you guys with
actually a listener of
caste who is also a huge fan of Seneca
so the book is Tao of Seneca ta o pal of
Seneca Sen EC a subtitle practical
letters from a stoic master and this is
effectively an introduction to what I
view is the ultimate operating system
for thriving and high stress
environments that is stoicism it's
become very popular among top athletic
Coaches CEOs and fast growing companies
so check it out that is for nonfiction
folks who must read or listen to
nonfiction now of Seneca practical
letters from a stoic master and as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you
have access to a 30-day trial and your
first audiobook is free so why not go
grab one of those ready player one or
town of Seneca go to audible.com forward
slash tim to start downloading now
membership includes one free audio book
every month exclusive sales just thirty
percent off all regularly priced
audiobooks and unlike streaming you own
your books once they have been
downloaded and I like to listen
oftentimes with them offline so you have
that benefit as well you can't make more
time folks just not manufacturing
anymore it's out of print you can't make
more time but you can make the most of
it so turn your travel commute dog walk
whatever into something more with a free
trial at audible.com forward slash Tim
to learn more and start now this episode
is brought to you by zip recruiter you
may have heard them everywhere they're
growing like crazy they're an innovative
platform for doing several things but
especially improving the hiring process
making it slick and elegant and easy one
of the hardest parts of running any
business growing any business is finding
and hiring the right team I've seen this
firsthand and close to a hundred
startups now god I'm getting old
from all over the world at different
stages of death and that nothing can
quite drain your resources and cost you
time and money like making mistakes in
hiring Zipp recruiter developed their
own system and their own platform for
helping you to solve to the biggest
problems and bottlenecks for employers
posting jobs easily and then making it
even easier to find the best candidates
unlike other job sites zip recruiter
does in effect the opposite of what
you'd expect so they do not depend on
candidates finding you their technology
finds the right candidate for you and in
fact more than 80% of the jobs posted on
zip recruiter returned a qualified
candidate based on your criteria that
you select in just 24 hours
so no more juggling email viewing
hundreds of unqualified candidates I've
been there done that don't recommend it
we're dealing with calls to the office
etc none of that simply screen rate and
manage your candidates all in one place
on zipper critters dashboard and there's
a listener of the Tim Ferriss show
thanks for that zip recruiter wants to
allow you to start posting jobs and
trying their services for free so if
you're thinking of hiring somebody you
need to find me an executive assistant
you need to find a developer whatever it
might be
try it out just visit zip recruiter comm
or slash Tim and you can experience just
how zip recruiter has been used by
businesses of all different sizes to
find it most qualified job candidates
again that's the zip recruiter dot-com
forward slash Tim check it out give a
spin
[Music]
[Applause]